Josh Stan I'm thrilled for you and your
entire organization so let's get right
to it let's give out the
[Music]
[Applause]
Rings receiving their Rings first Stan
and Josh KY stewards of a nuggets team
that went 16 and4 during that historic
playoff run they took out the
Timberwolves they blocked the Suns they
swept the
Lakers and they beat the heat on the way
to their very first NBA
championship boys those look
[Applause]
good next to receive their Rings it is
my pleasure to introduce the architect
and bench boss of your Denver Nuggets
please welcome general manager Calvin
booth and head coach Michael
[Applause]
Malone
coach Malone the microphone is all yours
my
friend nuggets
Nation I can't hear you
you guys have been the best fans in the
NBA for eight years we appreciate
that last year was amazing we got one
ring who wants
another let's go get it love
you
thank you coach your dad your dad is
proud right
now without further
delay let's start handing out some
bling we begin with the veteran Voice
number six
DeAndre
Jordan
up next the Colorado kid number seven
Reggie
Jackson
[Applause]
wearing number zero the freshly shaven
Christian
Brown
number
22 sweet music zek
[Applause]
Nagi
number
31 the V is for
vco
[Applause]
cha
up next number eight jumping jaet Payton
[Applause]
Watson number 21 Villanova finest Colin
gespi number one Mr
Smooth Michael Porter
Jor
Here Comes number five
kcp cavius God
[Applause]
number 50 AG Aaron
Gard
number
27 the
heartbeat jum
[Applause]
[Music]
M and
finally the man in the middle the two
time
MVP
Nicola
[Applause]
yic
now that the players have received their
Rings please turn your attention to the
ball Arena board for a video about these
one of the kind
[Music]
Rings the 47-year wait is over the
Denver Nugget are
Champion to n world
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
and now here to say a few words on
behalf of the 2023
Champions Aaron
Garden yo yo
yo listen
uh on behalf of my teammates uh my
training staff my coaching staff uh the
management and Ki Sports we just want to
say thank you from the bottom of our
hearts for uh experiencing this journey
with
[Applause]
us it's only right since last season
ended in Denver only makes sense that
this season starts in Denver too
baby
so thank you for coming out and
supporting tonight and all season long
on our road to repeat
[Applause]
[Music]
peace thank you AG will the team please
make your way over to that Banner box
for the unveiling of our Championship
Banner who's ready to see this
[Applause]
[Music]
Banner
[Applause]
[Music]
nuggets Nation on your feet it is time
to raise this Banner to the
Mountaintop in three 2
one raise it
[Applause]
[Music]
up after my
sentence but committ no
[Applause]
crime well those guys uh studying those
championship ring Shaq there's a lot to
cover in that uh yeah shout out to Jason
of Beverly Hill Jason at Beverly Hill
shout about too good job man every year
they do a great job right that's that's
just a cool moment especially for a
franchise that had been waiting so long
and they finally get that first one and
normally
look I haven't seen Joker smiling that
much yeah that's true for a long time he
normally Just Smiles when Shaq tries to
speak Serbian to him but but this was
what he's always been talking about is
it's all about winning it's all about
claiming a championship and he got it
done he he he and his teammates he
reminds me very much of the demeanor of
hakee elijuan like hakee when we won the
championship wasn't jumping on the
stanion but when we got the ring he was
super excited that night uh you know it
was the first championship for the for
Houston in any sport when we want it and
so this here I understand what that
moment feels but the same demeanor as an
Elijah Juan that strictly business but
it's good to see him smile and this just
solidifies and put a stamp on all the
hard work that you put in and you got it
done but you know the good thing about
sports is it starts all over tonight was
a great ceremony but you know guys like
us that are competitors we don't care
what you did last year let's see if you
can repeat that's a hell of a ring right
there